pays du moyen-orient le plus touché par
la pandémie de kobe 19 l'iran cherche à
enrayer la propagation du virus
ce samedi les autorités ont fait part de
leurs inquiétudes à propos d'une
possible recrudescence des cas de
contamination
depuis le 11 avril les petits commerces
ont été autorisés à rouvrir par le
gouvernement une décision qui va à
l'encontre des préconisations émises par
les responsables sanitaires qui redoute
une nouvelle vague épidémique
plus tôt dans la semaine le président
hassan rohani s'est tourné vers son
homologue russe en vue de renforcer la
coopération face au co vide 19
dans un appel téléphonique aujourd'hui
avec le président poutine
nous avons convenu de l'importance de la
coopération internationale pour lutter
contre le coc vide 19
nous avons également convenu que l'union
européenne doit prendre des mesures
contre les comportements illégaux des
états unis y compris son veto à la
demande de prêt de l'iran au fmi pour
lutter contre la pandémie
téhéran et moscou mettront en oeuvre les
accords le gouvernement iranien continue
d'inciter la population à respecter les
règles de distanciation sociale et les
consignes d'hygiène
un membre du ministère de la santé
spécialisée dans les maladies
infectieuses constate une augmentation
du nombre de cas dans certaines régions
du pays
dans certaines provinces comme guy
lannes comme et mazen dharan où nous
avons déployé de grands efforts afin de
contrôler l'épidémie
nous observons des signes d'une nouvelle
recrudescence
nous constatons une augmentation du
nombre de cas en particulier dans les
provinces traditionnellement les plus
visités en plus de cette situation
sanitaire délicate et on doit faire face
à la pression américaine
ce samedi mike pompéo a réclamé le
maintien de l'embargo sur les ventes
d'armes à l'iran au délà du mois
d'octobre
une annonce qui intervient quelques
jours après le lancement d'un satellite
militaire iranien source de nouvelles
tensions avec washington